let's go live to the Atlanta Airport
where our good friend Westwood one two
zone he's got about ten different jobs
former Patriot great offensive lineman
Ross Tucker joining the show Ross set
the scene are you at the airport right
now I am at the airport Paulie I am
sweating I'm drenched and I'm always
happy when I talk to you guys and this
is probably the happiest I've ever been
in my life I'm gonna make my flight and
it was looking very very dire so just
set the scene okay I had to do my Sirius
XM show till 8:00 to give myself a
little cushion I left with a segment
last Solomon Wilcox took over for me had
a car waiting was feeling great about it
got to the airport by 8:15 8:20 for a
9:30 flight come in here check my bag
there's two hour wait line even in TSA
pre did you use your physicality you're
what six four here still about 262 use
your physicality to get through security
do you bang out some media members no
well that's what I do when I have to get
interviews like in the media scrums at
the Super Bowl like media availability I
go on my toes or I elbow I actually like
to push people that I know and see how
far they'll let me push me before they
look at me and they sort of get mad and
they realize it's me you know I'll just
like subtly nudge them but how about
this I ask a guy oh my god man what do
we need to do what's what my flights at
9:30 he's like you on the International
shuttle and go over the International
Terminal I said okay so where's that so
I run over to the International shuttle
there's a line that looks like it's 40
mescon the International shuttle so I
try to get in the cab line there's a guy
get in the cab I hear him say
International Terminal I'm like dude can
I jump in with you he said yes so we
have four guys all trying to do the same
thing jump in the same cab the driver
wouldn't take us because it's not a long
enough drive for him it's not long
enough trip so we're all offering him
all kinds of money just to drive us here
we get to the International Terminal I
hop out TSA pre is still like 25 30
minutes so I go to the lady that's in
charge I show her a picture of my
daughters and I say I've been away for
nine days they're six and
five is there anything you can do my
place at 9:30 she said well you can go
here and priority I said priority that
sounds good
i priority that's for me so she takes me
to the front of line I get through go
through international hop on a shuttle
just about to board my flight and I'm
ecstatic because they don't have a lot
of direct flights to Harrisburg
Pennsylvania as you might imagine so I
made it we did it and everybody
listening I know there's a great deal
about this Lots in France
no rush we're really happy you made it
I'm gonna hit you with the DP Show poll
question for today was the Superbowl a
good game oh I like the way you phrase
that mclovin I think it was a good game
and I'll tell you why most important
thing to me is that the contest is in
doubt throughout and it really was you
know you get to the point where you've
got Jared Goff moving the ball down the
field to try to get a game-tying
touchdown you know I'll take that over
the Seahawks blowing out the Broncos in
New York City you know midway through
the second quarter you knew the game was
over I'll also say this there weren't a
lot of replays there was no
controversial call which clouded the
judgment of the outcome the better team
won I thought it was more great defense
and it was bad offense now look there
was some bad offense involved but I was
amazed at how prepared the guys were on
defense for both teams I mean and I'm a
consumer and Dante Fowler making plays
on screens and drawers and jet sweeps I
thought it was a really well played well
coached game in which the defense's had
the upper hand I think that two weeks
they were able to house himself up I
mean McVeigh said after the game McLovin
that the Patriots have been playing a
lot of man and then Devin McCourty told
me after the game that it's the most
zone they played all year and that's why
I think it looked like Jared Goff was
seeing ghosts out there so I will say I
thought it was a I thought it was a good
game I'm not gonna say great game but
I'll say if the poll questions good I'll
go with yes it was a good game so it
felt like the officials were letting
them play last night and like you're
saying there was no controversial calls
really and it didn't seem like there's
necessarily
a lot of penalties what is why is that
is that just a crude decision or is that
a reaction to the games leading up to
this well why is it that they let them
play
you know Sina I actually think that they
tell them before the playoffs - when in
doubt let them play and I think that's
one and by the way I like that right we
none of us want to see a lot of flags in
the playoffs I think we all like that
they want the action to be decided on
the field more but I actually think that
that's one of the reasons why they
didn't throw the flag in the Saints Rams
game on Mikkel Robbie Coleman I think
that the ref that was there had a bad
angle he thought it was a bang-bang play
and I think they are told in the
playoffs when in doubt don't throw the
flag and I thought last night was more
of that you know some people were saying
well if it was Brady that got blasted on
the sidelines like golf did that they
would have thrown the flag but let's now
forget I mean earlier in the game Aaron
Donald slung down Brady and I'm telling
you in the regular season now that would
be a penalty so I think it was all fair
in the secondary
you know Peters was pretty physical as
was tough on Gilmore I thought all of
those were good no calls I thought it
was a really cleanly well played game
even that the foul they called on Roby
Coleman I thought some people are
complaining about that I thought that
was textbook helmet the helmet of a
defenseless receiver you know Burkett
had just caught the ball so I think they
let him play and I think that we're all
the better off for it I don't think
anybody wants stoppages of play more
replays more flags I mean we all get
annoyed when we said there's this rough
realize that the game is not about him
so I'm glad their game was not about the
refs last night for a lot of reason Ross
Tucker Westwood one sports joining us in
the Dan Patrick show I'm a Rams fan out
there today I'm frustrated what happened
to my office can you see what happened
to their offense and do you blame them
or do you just more give credit to the
Patriots defensive plan I would say it's
like you guys know already it's always a
combination of both I did think that the
Patriots had a really good plan they
could not get the run game going you
know eight consecutive third downs they
can't convert it just makes it so hard
to get any type of flow any type of
consistency when
you can't get any first ounce and you
look at it they had a great plan Gilmore
a lot of times was matched up with cooks
he was excellent but I don't also say
this Paulie I mean you think about toys
Brandon cooks had the ball in his hands
in the endzone right now I'm a
coordinated tremendous play with his
left hand to rip it down and Doron
Harmon made a terrific play as well to
knock the ball out of his hands but
still I mean you got to make you gotta
catch at least one of those quickly Ross
look at No Ross you're a former Patriot
offensive lineman close personal friend
of Tom Brady did you make the cut for
the after party the Patriots after-party
so first of all I know you're being
facetious but I'm definitely not a close
personal friend of Tom Brady's we're
hung out socially like three or four
times
pretty good I did not make the cut and I
did not ask to make the cut because by
the time I got back to my hotel and
recorded my podcast
it was 1:15 a.m. and I got up at 4:15
a.m. because I had to go back in a new
bird downtown to do my 6:00 a.m. Sirius
XM show so I mean it would have been fun
to be around those guys but I can drink
daddy sodas whenever I want I wanted to
get at least three hours of sleep Ross
your Twitter feed last night was kind of
an ugly scene I sensed a real
dissatisfaction with the media room food
especially halftime potato chips what
happened yeah this is interesting too
because I actually have my pass allowed
me to have a spot in the auxilary locker
room I mean the auxilary press box area
but the issue with that is you're in the
stands and there's no TV so I literally
don't even want it like the most
important thing to me is so that when
I'm talking on my podcast or but you
guys are on my radio show but I'm able
to really see all the replays and really
see stuff and not be in the upper corner
of the end zone so I chose to be in the
media work room instead the pregame meal
was they had mixed greens which is
lovely balsamic vinaigrette and then
they had five containers of chicken
fingers so not one or two or three
there's five separate containers of the
exact same chicken fingers but I will
say those were actually delicious
so I cut that up
on top of my lettuce and had like a
crazy healthy breaded chicken salad I
guess nobody is just like you know and
here's the thing though at halftime all
they had was Lay's chips there was
something happened and they sent the
food to the wrong place so a pregame
I eat it like 3:30 okay now it's
halftime and all they have is Lay's
potato chili number one you need to have
more food than that number two what
galaxy what world do we live in that if
you only have one potato chip it's Lay's
rather than Doritos I mean we
established when I was three years old
that Doritos are the best chips on the
planet they always have been
nobody debates it this isn't like a big
we all know so if they're only gonna
have one chip there have Doritos I would
eat the crap out of six bags of Doritos
but I don't like baked Lay's or whatever
it was thankfully at the end of the
third quarter they brought in like some
pulled pork but at that point the game
was going on so I grabbed the food by
didn't have a chance to do a video of it
because I I couldn't take the time now
bless you I didn't deserve a video if
the food wasn't there at halftime they
don't deserve a video see this all makes
so much more sense to me now because the
overwhelming narrative coming out of the
Super Bowl was that it was a really
terrible game well yeah if you have a
bunch of hungry reporters and media
members covering the game this is like a
Snickers commercial living out there
like you know what you know what's funny
about that scene you say that I know
you're kidding but I always think it's
so weird like what why these cities and
franchises don't have better press box
food it's not that big a deal
you're not spending that much money and
obviously if your team stunk they're
gonna say they stunk if your team's
great they're gonna say they're great
but wouldn't you want them to have a
positive impression for all of their
readers and listeners and everybody of
your city of your venue and of your food
it's not that hard
like any time I go to Green Bay I love
it
they've got pack and cheese they've got
plots they've got all kinds of great
stuff then you go Simmons other cities
and it's just garbage and I'll be honest
with ya I am an objective journalist but
they might not always get the benefit
based on their food that might and it's
subconscious it's not it's not a
conscious decision by me but look I I
commentate with my brain but mainly with
my belly nice alright final 30 seconds
Ross last night's game Julia net him in
CL a Hall of Fame entry with that
performance so I need to really sit down
and look at the numbers because I
thought it was laughable early in the
week when people were talking about
Edelman as a Hall of Fame I was like
what are you kidding I'm serious
like I really thought people were joking
when they were talking about Edelman as
a hall-of-famer now that he's a super
1bp
and now that he had data performance now
I need to take a closer look at it and
at least examine the numbers
I feel like though if guys like Isaac
Bruce can't get in and Torry Holt I'm
gonna have a tough time putting enjoying
that woman at this point but his career
is not over yet I mean maybe he has two
three four more years like it he would
be under sort of the the Lynn Swann
candidacy in other words like Lynn swans
in the Hall of Fame because those three
catches he had in those two Super Bowls
that we've all seen five bazillion times
that's going to be the Edelman thing
where I was like when I know men retires
five years after they gonna be like
remember that couch guys against the
Seahawks in the Super Bowl
remember when he dominated the Rams in
the Super Bowl I mean that's gonna be
his candidacy unless he plays you know
several more years Ross thanks a lot I
think I speak for everyone here saying
we're really proud of your work this
week not so much the football coverage
but fighting through the halftime potato
chip situation we'll talk to you soon
buddy good luck getting home
absolutely take care guys and I had
subway a couple times this week they did
have spicy mustard so that crisis has
been at least temporarily averted
thoughts and prayers spicy mustard for
life Ross Tucker thanks for joining us
the Dan Patrick for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]